This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. A couple of months ago, we asked you to share coincidences you've experienced. Lots of you called in with amazing stories. Nestled among them, were two stories that themselves formed a coincidence. So I was a student at the University of Rhode Island, and we were in this writing class. This is Amanda Birch. She was talking to the teacher of her writing class and the teacher mentioned that she lived
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。几个月前，我们邀请大家分享你们经历过的巧合。许多听众打来电话，分享了精彩的故事。在这些故事中，有两个故事本身就构成了一个巧合。我当时是罗德岛大学的学生，我们在一门写作课上。这是阿曼达·伯奇。她当时正在和写作课老师聊天，老师提到她住在
in a small town in Vermont. The same small town it turned out where Amanda's mother had grown up. The teacher asked Amanda what her mother's maiden name was and Amanda told her. She just kind of drops her pen and she goes, you're not gonna believe this, but I live in the house where your
佛蒙特州的一个小镇上。结果发现，那个小镇正是阿曼达的母亲长大的地方。老师问阿曼达她母亲的婚前姓氏是什么，阿曼达告诉了她。她差点把笔掉下来，然后说道：“你绝对不会相信，我住的房子就是你
mother grew up. The other listener who called us was Sarah Toproth. She called us on a scratchy phone line from Paris. Sarah's an American, but it's been living in France for several years. She was at a house party and someone there told her that there was another American in the room. So she went over to say hello. They started talking and...
母亲长大的地方。”另一位给我们打电话的听众是莎拉·托普罗斯。她通过一条杂音很重的电话线从巴黎打来电话。莎拉是个美国人，但在法国已经住了好几年。她当时在一个家庭派对上，有人告诉她房间里还有另一个美国人。于是她走过去打招呼。他们开始聊了起来……
So it turns out that this girl that I met at this house party in Paris grew up in the exact same house in Pacific New York as my father. What are the odds? We thought we might find out. This week, we'll talk about the mathematics of coincidences. That particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with, in a very strange place, I would say, perhaps 80% of all the coincidences I've heard fold into that category.
结果发现，我在巴黎这个派对上遇到的这个女孩，竟然和我父亲在纽约帕西フィック（译者注：此处音译或地名误读，保留原文语境即可，写作帕西）的房子是同一栋。几率有多大？我们觉得可以探究一下。本周，我们将探讨巧合背后的数学原理。那种特殊的巧合——在非常奇怪的地方遇到一个熟人或你熟悉的人——我想说，我听过的所有巧合中，大概有80%都属于这一类。
And we'll explore why we are drawn to coincidences, and what our fascination with them can tell us about the human mind. Whenever you see something that you can't explain, the natural human instinct is to try to understand it. But that can also mean that sometimes we over-explain things. We're starting today with a story about Whisper.
我们还将探讨为什么我们会被巧合吸引，以及我们对巧合的痴迷能告诉我们关于人类心灵的什么信息。每当你看到无法解释的事情时，人类的本能反应就是试图去理解它。但这有时也意味着我们会过度解释事物。我们今天从一个关于Whisper（耳语）的故事开始。
And just so you can understand this coincidence story, we're going to first explain what Whisper is and how it works. Whisper is an app that allows users to connect anonymously online. They can post messages or secrets, these are called Whisper's, and strangers can respond with their own Whisper's. We've asked a few producers to read out some of these Whisper's. I'm secretly planning my wedding on Pinterest. own whispers. We've asked a few producers to read out some of these whispers. The messages are short about the length of a tweet and they range from the silly to the very serious. Some months ago the folks at Whisper got in touch to tell us a story about an interesting
为了让大家理解这个巧合的故事，我们首先要解释一下Whisper是什么以及它是如何运作的。Whisper是一个允许用户在网上匿名连接的应用程序。他们可以发布消息或秘密，这些被称为“whispers”（耳语），陌生人可以用自己的“whispers”进行回复。我们请了几位制作人来朗读其中一些“whisper”。我正在Pinterest上秘密策划我的婚礼。自己的耳语。我们请了几位制作人来朗读其中一些耳语。这些消息很短，大约一条推文的长度，内容从恶作剧到非常严肃的事情不等。几个月前，Whisper的工作人员联系我们，向我们讲述了一个关于他们网站上发生的有趣
coincidence that happened on their site. Lauren Hudson is 27 and she turned to Whisper at one of the darkest moments of her life. I was in a really bad relationship. There was a lot of domestic violence involved and I didn't really know what to do or how to reach out to people or how to talk about it.
巧合的故事。劳伦·哈德森今年27岁，她在生命中最黑暗的时刻之一求助于Whisper。我当时陷入了一段非常糟糕的感情中。其中有很多家庭暴力，我真的不知道该怎么办，也不知道该如何向别人求助或谈论这件事。
So I used the app to connect with other women and to kind of vent and like find empowerment to get away from the person that I was with. Lauren was having trouble opening up about what was happening with her friends and family. I think I was scared to be completely honest. I think I had a lot of fear and I didn't want like any police involved. I didn't want like and I didn't want any police involved. I didn't want like, I didn't want it to turn into like this whole thing. But on Whisper she could be anonymous. She could seek support without all the immediate consequences.
所以我用这个应用程序与其他女性联系，发泄一下情绪，并从中获得力量，好让我能离开我当时在一起的那个人。劳伦很难向朋友和家人敞开心扉讲述发生的这一切。我想我是害怕完全诚实。我觉得自己有很多恐惧，而且我不想牵扯进任何警察。我不想像……我不想牵扯进任何警察。我不想像……我不想把它弄成这么大一件事。但在Whisper上，她是匿名的。她可以在没有所有直接后果的情况下寻求支持。
It was there in one of these threads that she started talking to a man. Lauren was touched by how much compassion he seemed to have for her, a complete stranger. It was almost as if he genuinely wanted to know how I was. Even though he didn't know who I was, and he knew that it was anonymous and who knows who he's talking to, he just genuinely wanted to know if I was okay. He was in a town nearby, another coincidence perhaps, and they started exchanging messages. They connected immediately, decided to meet in person. We got together and we went to Applebee's, and we sat and we talked for like,
正是在其中的一个帖子里，她开始和一个男人聊天。劳伦被他对她的同情心深深打动了，而她明明只是一个完全的陌生人。就好像他是真心想知道我过得怎么样。尽管他不知道我是谁，而且他知道这是匿名的，谁知道他在和谁说话，但他就是真心想知道我是否还好。他住在附近的一个城镇，也许这又是一个巧合，于是他们开始互发信息。他们一拍即合，决定见面。我们聚在一起去了Applebee's（苹果蜂餐厅），我们坐下来聊了大约，
I think it was like almost two hours that we just sat and talked. They became more and more inseparable. Lauren ended her unhealthy relationship and started dating this guy from Whisperr, Eric. And everything was going great. But Lauren was a little nervous about meeting Eric's family. Eric had brought Lauren home to have dinner with them and the whole time she was anxious.
我想大概有将近两个小时，我们只是坐在那里聊天。他们的关系变得越来越密不可分。劳伦结束了那段不健康的恋爱关系，开始和这个来自Whisper的男生埃里克约会。一切都进展得很顺利。但劳伦对去见埃里克的家人感到有点紧张。埃里克把劳伦带回家和他们一起吃晚饭，她全程都感到焦虑。
Like my palms were sweating and I felt like really hot. You know, so I didn't know if like if it was going down well or if I was totally blowing it. Like I didn't know what was going on. She was especially nervous about Eric's sister, Amanda. You know, I knew when I first met her, the first couple of times that we hung out and stuff. I knew that there was a little bit of a distance there and I knew that every time I went over to hang out with Eric and his family, those walls would slowly break down. But Lauren was impatient. She and Eric were getting engaged.
比如我的手心在出汗，我觉得自己真的很热。你知道的，所以我不知道这到底进展顺利还是我彻底搞砸了。我根本不知道发生了什么。她对埃里克的姐姐阿曼达尤其感到紧张。你知道的，我刚认识她的时候，我们一起出去玩过头几次的时候。我知道我们之间有点距离感，我也知道每次我去和埃里克及他的家人一起玩时，那些隔阂会慢慢打破。但劳伦有些不耐烦了。她和埃里克快要订婚了。
Lauren understood Amanda's attitude. She felt the same toward the girls her younger brother would bring home. Maybe I'll see them next week, or maybe I'll never see them again. You know what I mean? So that was kind of like what I had in my head. same toward the girls, her younger brother would bring home. Lauren wasn't going anywhere. She and Eric were getting engaged. Eric in fact had a flair for the romantic bringing her roses, comforting her with her favorite movie after a tough day, and he would tell his family about all this. So why couldn't Lauren break through with Amanda? All this time, Lauren was still on whisper. Now I use it instead of me looking for help, I use it to help others.
劳伦理解阿曼达的态度。她对她弟弟带回家的女孩也有同感。也许我下周会见到她们，或者也许我再也见不到她们了。你知道我的意思吗？所以这基本上就是我脑子里的想法。对她弟弟带回家的女孩也有同感。劳伦可不会轻易离开。她和埃里克快要订婚了。事实上，埃里克很有浪漫细胞，会给她送玫瑰，在她度过艰难的一天后用她最喜欢的电影安慰她，他还会把这一切告诉家人。那么，为什么劳伦就无法打破与阿曼达之间的坚冰呢？这段时间以来，劳伦仍然在使用Whisper。现在我不再用它来寻求帮助，而是用它来帮助别人。
That's my way of giving back because the whisper community helped me when I needed them. One day, she started exchanging messages with a woman who was going through a very painful break-up. I sent a big message, basically saying that it's okay, everyone goes to heartaches and there will be many more people out there. As a way to offer encouragement, Lauren told a woman about her own happy relationship. The woman asked Lauren about the nicest thing her fiancee had done for her. Lauren told her about the day Eric surprised her with her favorite movie. On my birthday, I had a really bad day at work.
这是我回馈社会的方式，因为在我需要的时候，Whisper社区曾帮助过我。有一天，她开始和一个正在经历痛苦分手的女人互发信息。我发了一条很长的消息，大意是说没关系，每个人都会经历心碎，外面还会有很多更好的人。为了鼓励对方，劳伦向这个女人讲述了她自己幸福的恋爱关系。这个女人问劳伦她的未婚夫为她做过的最贴心的事情是什么。劳伦告诉了她埃里克用她最喜欢的电影给她惊喜的那一天。在我生日那天，我在工作很不顺利。
It was like one of those days where you wake up and just from the moment you put your feet on the floor, everything goes wrong. So I didn't want to see him that day. I was just miserable. I just wanted to be home. Like, I was just, like, I just want to go to bed. And he surprised me with these beautiful flowers, these roses, and he had the notebook, which is my favorite, like, sappy love story of all time.
那就像那种你一醒来，从你双脚着地的那一刻起，所有事情都在出错的日子。所以我那天不想见他。我简直痛苦不堪。我只想呆在家里。就像，我当时只是觉得，我只想去睡觉。但他却用这些美丽的鲜花、这些玫瑰给了我一个惊喜，他还带来了《恋恋笔记本》（The Notebook），这是我这辈子最喜欢的、最感人的爱情故事。
Lauren finished telling her story and waited for her reply. Her first response after I sent that story to her, she's like, Lauren. Like she, Lauren, I was like, how do you know my name? You know, because it's all anonymous. And she's like, this is Amanda. Amanda, Eric's sister, the very person, she'd been trying so desperately to connect with in real life.
劳伦讲完她的故事，等待着对方的回复。在我把那个故事发给她后，她的第一反应是，劳伦。就像她，劳伦，我当时想，你怎么知道我的名字？你知道的，因为这一切都是匿名的。然后她说，我是阿曼达。阿曼达，埃里克的姐姐，也就是她一直在现实生活中拼命想要与之拉近距离的那个人。
Lauren says this coincidence changed her whole relationship with Amanda, connecting random very person, she'd been trying so desperately to connect with in real life. Lauren says this coincidence changed her whole relationship with Amanda. Connecting randomly online and revealing intimate details about themselves, made the two women feel closer. Many of us have experienced these kinds of coincidences. You bump into your kindergarten friend, your first day in college, or you meet someone at a party and discover she lives in your dad's childhood home in Prokipsi. When these kinds of coincidences happen in our lives, they feel like magic.
劳伦说，这个巧合彻底改变了她和阿曼达的关系，把那些原本随机的……也就是她一直在现实生活中拼命想要与之拉近距离的那个人。劳伦说，这个巧合彻底改变了她和阿曼达的关系。通过在网上随机相连并透露彼此的亲密细节，让这两个女人感觉更加亲近了。我们许多人都经历过这种巧合。比如你上大学第一天撞见了幼儿园的朋友，或者你在派对上遇到某人，却发现她住在你爸爸在波基普西（Poughkeepsie）的童年老宅里。当这种巧合发生在我们的生活中时，它们感觉就像魔法一样。
But as any mathematician will tell you, things that feel unusual or even impossible are actually fairly common. Mathematician Joseph Muser knows this, but he was reluctant to write a book that would dispel the magic. In the end though, Joseph did write his book, it's called Fluke, the math and myth of coincidence. It's full of stories of people who find themselves experiencing things that feel so unlikely. But Joseph Maeser says, if you study this for a while, the coincidences start to fall into certain categories.
但正如任何数学家都会告诉你的那样，那些感觉不同寻常甚至不可能的事情，实际上相当普遍。数学家约瑟夫·梅泽（Joseph Mazur）深知这一点，但他起初很不愿写一本会打破这种神奇感书。不过最终，约瑟夫还是写了这本书，书名叫《乱数：巧合的数学与神话》（Fluke: The Math and Myth of Coincidence）。书中充满了各种人们发现自己经历了如此不可思议的事情的故事。但约瑟夫·梅泽表示，如果你研究一段时间，这些巧合就会开始落入某些特定的类别。
And the stories we heard from our two listeners, as well as Lauren's story about meeting her soon-to-be sister-in-law in Whisper are all basically the same type of coincidence, which in itself is not a coincidence. If you categorize these coincidences to, let's say, ten different categories, that particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with. In a very strange place, I would say perhaps 80% of all the coincidence I've heard fold into that category. Joseph Mauser says the reason these coincidences feel extraordinary, but actually are not so extraordinary, is because of a common misconception about the number of people we think we actually know.
我们从两位听众那里听到的故事，以及劳伦在Whisper上遇到她即将成为小姑子的故事，基本上都是同一种类型的巧合，这本身并不是巧合。如果你把这些巧合归纳为，比方说十个不同的类别，那么那种特殊的巧合——在非常奇怪的地方遇到一个熟人或你熟悉的人。我想说，在我听过的所有巧合中，大概有80%都属于这一类。约瑟夫·梅泽表示，这些巧合之所以让人觉得非同寻常，但实际上并非如此，是因为人们对我们实际认识的人数存在一个普遍的误解。
People think that their address book is essentially the people they know and it turns out that any particular address book is about 1% of the people they actually know in some way. In other words, a neighbor, some of the bump into in the street, but the dress book is about 1% of the people they know. As a result, the odds of bumping into someone you know are much greater than you think, because you know many more people than you think. Sometimes math can help us understand the magic. Magic like winning the lottery, not just once, but several times. That's what happened to a woman named Joan Ginther.
人们认为他们的通讯录基本上就代表了他们认识的人，但事实证明，任何一本特定的通讯录大概只占他们实际上以某种方式认识的人的1%左右。换句话说，一个邻居，某个你在街上偶然撞到的人，通讯录里的人只占你认识的人的1%。因此，你偶然遇到熟人的几率比你想象的要大得多，因为你认识的人比你想象的要多得多。有时数学能帮助我们理解这种神奇。比如赢得彩票的神奇，不仅中一次，而是中好几次。一个名叫琼·金瑟（Joan Ginther）的女人就经历了这样的事。
In 1993, I think it was, she won $5.4 million in Texas Lotto. 13 years later, she won again $2 million. And then a few years after that, she won $3 million. And then in 2010, she won $3 million, and then in 2010, she won $10 million. What are the odds of one person winning the lottery four times? Yeah, the odds are, I think somebody made a calculation, and I did too, that the odds are about 18 Septilion to one against it happening. 18 Septilion to one against it happening.
我想大概是在1993年，她赢得了德克萨斯州彩票的540万美元。13年后，她再次赢得了200万美元。再过几年，她又赢了300万美元。然后在2010年，她赢了300万美元，接着在2010年，她又赢了1000万美元。一个人连续四次中彩票的几率是多少？是的，这个几率是，我想有人做过计算，我也算过，发生这种事的几率大约是18万京（18 septillion，即1后面有24个零）分之一。发生这种事的几率是18万京分之一。
18 Septilion to one. That's incomprehensible. For those who are not mathematicians, a Septilion is one followed by 24 zeros. But Joseph Mauser says, we're actually asking the wrong question. Think about it this way. If I buy a lottery ticket and I ask the question, what are the odds that I will win? My odds are very small. But if I ask, what are the odds that anyone will win the lottery? In a country of hundreds of millions of people, the odds are actually much higher. So if you ask the question slightly differently, not what are the odds that Joan Guinter will win the lottery four times, but what are the odds that anyone will win four times? You get a very different answer. I think I calculated one point about 5 million to one, which is not anywhere near the septillions. It's about 5 million to one, and that takes into account the fact that we have thousands
18万京分之一。这简直不可思议。对于不懂数学的人来说，“京”（septillion）就是1后面跟着24个零。但约瑟夫·梅泽说，我们其实问错了问题。换个角度想一想。如果我买了一张彩票，然后问：我中奖的几率是多少？我的几率非常小。但如果我问：任何人中彩票的几率是多少？在一个拥有数亿人口的国家里，这个几率实际上要高得多。所以，如果你稍微改变一下问题，不是问琼·金瑟连续四次中彩票的几率是多少，而是问任何人连续四次中奖的几率是多少？你会得到一个非常不同的答案。我想我计算的结果大约是500万分之一，这与“京”相去甚远。大约是500万分之一，而且这已经考虑到了世界上有成千上万种彩票的事实。我的意思是，有很多彩票，其中许多都是大型彩票。所以500万分之一，虽然仍然不太可能，但并非不可理解。
of lottery in the world. I mean, there are many lotteries and many of them are big time lotteries. So 5 million to one, still unlikely, but not incomprehensible. What makes it even more comprehensible is the fact that most lottery winners don't stop gambling when they win. And you do find that almost everybody who does win a lottery fairly big time spends all that money or much of that money in trying to win again. Joseph Miser says this might have been the case with John Ginter. You win 5.4 million dollars. You have you have a money to play with. You have house money. So you're you're taking the house money to bet again and
让它更容易理解的一个事实是，大多数彩票得主中奖后并没有停止赌博。你会发现，几乎所有真正赢得了一笔巨额彩票的人，都会把所有的钱或者大部分钱用来试图再次中奖。约瑟夫·梅泽说，琼·金瑟可能就是这种情况。你赢了540万美元。你有钱可以挥霍了。你用的是“赌场给的钱”（house money，即用赢来的利润去下注）。所以你是在用赢来的钱再次下注，
her odds of winning a second time are better than most people because she's got the money to play with. She wins the second time, then she's playing with more money. And you can see the between the first winning and the second winning, it was 13 years, between the second winning and the third, it was only two years, and between the third and the fourth was only two years as well. So Joseph Mauser can wrap his head around what happened to Joan Gynther, but there are some coincidences that just defy mathematical interpretation. Joseph told me one of his favorite stories about a 19th century French poet Emil de
她第二次中奖的几率比大多数人都要高，因为她有钱可以用来玩。她第二次中奖了，然后她手里有了更多的钱。你可以看到，第一次中奖和第二次中奖之间隔了13年，第二次中奖和第三次中奖之间只隔了2年，第三次和第四次之间也只隔了2年。所以约瑟夫·梅泽能够理解琼·金瑟身上发生的事情，但有些巧合简直违背了数学上的解释。约瑟夫跟我讲了他最喜欢的一个故事，关于19世纪的法国诗人埃米尔·德尚（Emil de Champ）。
Champ. Emil de Champ, as a teenager, he meets a man by the name of a strange name, Monsieur de Forti-Bou. He turns out to be an immigrant from England, and a Forti-Bou introduces him to a plum pudding. It's a very English dish that's almost unheard of in France. Ten years go by, and Dixamp is passing a restaurant in Paris. There's a sign on the window saying that they have plum pudding on their menu. But when Dixamp goes inside, he stole the last of the plum pudding was just sold to a gentleman
埃米尔·德尚在青少年时期，遇到过一个名字叫得很奇怪的人——德·福蒂布（Monsieur de Fortibu）先生。这个人原来是个来自英国的移民，德·福蒂布向他介绍了一种名为“普拉姆布丁”（plum pudding，梅子布丁）的食物。这是一种非常地道的英国菜，在法国几乎闻所未闻。十年过去了，德尚路过巴黎的一家餐厅。窗户上挂着一个牌子，上面写着他们的菜单上有梅子布丁。但当德尚走进去时，他被告知最后一份梅子布丁刚刚卖给了一位
sitting in the back. The waiter calls out loud. Mr. DeFotinbou, would you be willing to share your plum pudding with this gentleman? You're as pass. D'Sham is now at a dinner party with some friends. The host announces an unusual dessert will be served. Plum pudding. And the shamp jokes that one of the guests to arrive must be Mr. De Forte Boone.
坐在后面的绅士。服务员大声喊道：德·福蒂布先生，您愿意把您的梅子布丁分给这位绅士吗？时过境迁。德尚现在正和一些朋友参加一个晚宴。主人宣布将上一道不同寻常的甜点：梅子布丁。德尚开玩笑说，即将到达的客人之一一定就是德·福蒂布先生。
Well, as soon as the doorbell rings, then Mr. De Forte Boone is announced. And he enters, he's an old man by now, but the shamp recognizes him. Mr. De Fort and the food looks around and realizes that he's in the wrong apartment. He was invited to a dinner, but not in that apartment. I love that because it's a triple coincidence
嗯，门铃一响，德·福蒂布先生就被宣布进场了。他走了进来，现在已经是一位老人了，但德尚一眼就认出了他。德·福蒂布环顾四周，意识到自己走错了公寓。他是被邀请去参加晚宴的，但不是在这间公寓。我太喜欢这个故事了，因为这是一个三重巧合，
and it has a beautiful story element with it. I mean, that's so magnificent. And that's why, that's the kind of coincidence I love to hear. Joseph Maser, Professor of Mathematics and author of Fluke, the Math and Myth of Coincidence. When we come back, we're going to look at what Coincidence's reveal about the mind, in particular, and fascinated by something I've observed in my own life. When I experience a coincidence, it invariably feels more meaningful to me than it does to others.
并且它具有非常美妙的故事元素。我的意思是，这太宏大了。这就是为什么，这就是我最喜欢听的那类巧合。约瑟夫·梅泽，数学教授兼《乱数：巧合的数学与神话》一书的作者。稍后回来，我们将探讨巧合揭示了人类心灵的什么奥秘，特别是，我对我自己在生活中观察到的某种现象感到十分着迷。每当我经历巧合时，它总是让我觉得比对其他人更有意义。
Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. I'm fascinated by coincidences and could listen for hours to stories about them. But what is it that so fascinates us about these moments in life? At the University of Chicago, psychologists Nick Eppley thinks he might have one answer. He's the author of the book mind-wise. To understand how Eppley thinks about coincidences, I need to take a moment and explain his broader work to you first.
请不要走开。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我对巧合深感着迷，可以连续几个小时听别人讲这类的故事。但是，到底是什么让我们对生活中的这些时刻如此着迷呢？在芝加哥大学，心理学家尼克·埃普利（Nick Eppley）认为他可能找到了一个答案。他是《心灵智慧》（Mindwise）一书的作者。为了理解埃普利对巧合的看法，我需要先花点时间向大家解释一下他更广泛的研究工作。
Eppley's book examines how we read the mental states and intentions of other people. This is a remarkably useful skill, but we sometimes misapply it. We sometimes attribute intentionality to things that aren't even living, especially when they're out of the ordinary. For example, we don't personify a sunny day, but we give hurricanes a name, Katrina, Sandy, Andrew. After Hurricane Katrina, the mayor of New Orleans said, God must be mad at America. This isn't new.
埃普利的书探讨了我们如何解读其他人的心理状态和意图。这是一项非常有用技能，但我们有时会误用它。我们有时会将意向性赋予那些甚至没有生命的事物，尤其是当它们不同寻常的时候。例如，我们不会将晴朗的天气人格化，但我们会给飓风起名字：卡特里娜、桑迪、安德鲁。卡特里娜飓风过后，新奥尔良市长说，上帝一定是对美国生气了。这并不是什么新鲜事。
For centuries, people have ascribed intentionality to natural forces. We think storms, droughts, and earthquakes must have a mind of their own. This general tendency to explain behaviors in terms of purpose or intent or meaning is often quite a successful thing to do. Turns out we live with other people who do have intentions and goals and foresight and planning and meaning behind their actions. And so by and large that tendency to make those kinds of attributions to other people is a good way to learn about each other, is a good way to explain why other people did something in the past, to predict how they're likely to behave in the future.
几个世纪以来，人们一直将意向性归咎于自然力量。我们认为风暴、干旱和地震一定有它们自己的思想。这种用目的、意图或意义来解释行为的普遍倾向，通常是一种非常成功的做法。事实证明，我们身边的确生活着其他具有意图、目标、远见、规划以及行动背后意义的人。因此，总的来说，对其他人做出这种归因的倾向，是了解彼此的好方法，是解释其他人过去为什么那样做的好方法，也是预测他们未来可能如何表现的好方法。
But the problem with any kind of good tool is that sometimes we use it a little too much. And that's what happens in these cases where you're trying to explain the behavior of something that doesn't really have a sensible explanation for it. Some random events, some chance occurrence, some physical anomaly, some weather pattern that crops up that might not in fact have a mind behind it. This is why we are fascinated by robots that move in unpredictable ways. What we found was that when people were given a description of an object that made it sound unpredictable, like you couldn't anticipate its actions.
但任何好工具的问题在于，有时我们会过度使用它。这就是为什么当你试图解释某种并没有合理解释的事物行为时，就会发生这种情况。比如一些随机事件、偶然的发生、某种物理异常、或者突然出现可能背后并没有主观意识的某种天气模式。这就是为什么我们会对以不可预测方式移动的机器人着迷。我们发现，当人们被赋予对某个物体的描述，使其听起来不可预测，比如你无法预料它的行动时。
That's when people described it or reported that it had more mental states. They were more willing to say that the object has a mind of its own, that it has intentions, for instance. And I don't think this is totally counterintuitive that is a mind. If you see, for instance, a billured ball sitting on a table, another ball comes along and hits it,
这就是人们描述或报告它具有更多心理状态的时候。他们更愿意说这个物体有自己的思想，比如它有意图。我认为这完全不是违反直觉的，它就是一个有思想的东西。如果你看到，比方说，一个台球静止在桌子上，另一个球滚过来撞了它一下，
and that ball rolls off in the predicted direction, well, you don't need anything to explain that. But if you've got a ball sitting on a table, and it suddenly starts rolling around randomly, well, then you've got something to explain. And in these cases, sometimes people look to the inside of an agent, give it a mind, maybe the ball is possessed, maybe there's a demon controlling it, moving it around the table.
然后那个球按预期的方向滚开了，好吧，你不需要任何解释。但如果你有一个球放在桌子上，它突然开始毫无规律地到处乱滚，好吧，那你就得找个解释了。在这种情况下，有时人们会去寻找某种代理的内部机制，给它赋予一个思想，也许这个球被附身了，也许有个恶魔在控制它，让它在桌子上移动。
Sometimes people attribute a mind to something when it's not there, but they do that as an effort to explain what's going on in this autonomous, in this autonomous agent. And they're more likely to do that when an agent behaves somewhat unpredictably. I was over at a friend's house and my friend has a wonderful pool and he had set this underwater rumble for the lack of a better term to clean the bottom of the pool. So it sort of rolls around the bottom of the pool
有时，当某种思想并不存在时，人们也会将其归因于某个事物，但他们这样做是为了努力解释这个自主的、这个自主代理中正在发生的事情。当一个代理的行为表现得有些不可预测时，他们就更有可能这样做。我曾经去一个朋友家，我朋友有一个非常棒的泳池，他放了一个水下机器人——为了找不到更好的词来称呼它——来清理泳池底部。所以它有点像在泳池底部滚来滚去，
and it goes in this completely random fashion, right? So it just runs for a couple of hours. It's cleaning the bottom of the pool and I found myself fascinated just watching it because the fact that you can't predict what it's going to do next makes it just more interesting and more alive in a way than something that moves in a very predictable fashion. Absolutely. Something that moves robotically, very predictably, that is just a mindless machine. But when your roomba is going around randomly,
而且它以这种完全随机的方式行进，对吧？所以它就这样运行几个小时。它在清理泳池底部，我发现自己看得入迷了，仅仅是因为你无法预测它下一步要做什么，比起那些以非常可预测的方式移动的东西，它在某种程度上显得更有趣、更有生命力。绝对是这样。像机器人一样移动、非常可预测的东西，那只是一台没有思想的机器。但是当你的Roomba（扫地机器人）在随机乱跑时，
well, now it wants to go over there a little bit. Now it wants to move over here. Now it realizes it didn't clean that side of the pool over there. Things that behave randomly start to get a little sense of a mind. Now people aren't crazy. You don't think it's like your mother, right, or your spouse who's vacuuming the living room. But it starts to look just a little bit more mindful. In fact, the Rumbas are good example. People actually do name their Rumbas. You can buy outfits to dress it up.
好吧，现在它想去那边一点。现在它想移到这里。现在它意识到它还没清理泳池的那一边。那些表现随机的事物开始带有一点点思想的感觉。当然，人们并不是疯了。你不会觉得它就像你的母亲，对吧，或者像在客厅吸尘的配偶。但它开始看起来确实更有思想了一点。事实上，Roomba就是一个很好的例子。人们真的会给他们的Roomba起名字。你甚至可以买衣服来给它们打扮。
If you Google this online, you'll find all kinds of examples of people thinking of their Rumbas having perhaps a little bit more of a mind than it really does. I want to talk to you a little bit about the subject of coincidences. And I thought of you in your work because it feels to me that when something unusual happens to us and we stop and we say, that is weird. I was just reading this word in a book a second ago and someone in the room around me mentions the very same word. And it makes you stop and look up just like I stop and
如果你在网上谷歌一下，你会发现各种各样的例子，人们觉得自己的Roomba可能比实际上拥有更多的思想。我想和你聊聊关于巧合这个主题。我想到了你和你的工作，因为我觉得，当一些不寻常的事情发生在我们身上时，我们会停下来然后说：这太诡异了。我刚才在书里读到这个词，而我周围房间里的某个人就提到了完全相同的词。这让你停下来抬头看，就像我停下来看着那个水下Roomba一样。
look at that underwater rumba. Absolutely. That's a case where something unusual happens. It was unpredictable and you try to explain it. You can explain these kinds of random coincidences in lots of different ways. There are lots of different kinds of causal structures we might be able to put on it. But some of them involve giving it more meaning than it actually has. This is what underwater rumbers have to do with coincidences.
绝对是这样。这正是不寻常的事情发生的情况。它是不可预测的，而你试图去解释它。你可以用很多不同的方式来解释这种随机的巧合。我们可能会把许多不同种类的因果结构强加给它。但其中有些解释赋予了它比实际更多的意义。这就是水下Roomba与巧合的关系。
Like a robot that does something unexpected, coincidences cry out for meaning or explanation because they're out of the ordinary. We start to seek patterns even when they aren't any. My favorite example of this in the world of psychology is actually phenomena first documented by my PhD advisor, Tom Gilevich, and the brilliant psychologist, Amos Tversky, is the illusion of the hot hand in basketball.
就像一个做出意料之外举动的机器人一样，巧合由于不同寻常，而迫切需要意义或解释。即使根本没有任何规律，我们也开始寻找规律。在心理学界，我最喜欢的这方面的例子其实是由我的博士导师汤姆·吉洛维奇（Tom Gilovich）和杰出的心理学家阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky）首次记录的现象，也就是篮球运动中“火手”（hot hand，手感火热）的错觉。
Danny Green again from downtown. He said six and a row are going back to game two. The myth is that, when shooting free throws, basketball players get on a roll. People believe that basketball players get a hot hand, and that their times when they're on and the chance of making a basket is higher after they've just made one than after they've just missed one. Eplea is insane basketball players don't have streaks. He's saying we draw the wrong conclusion about these streaks. Let's imagine that they're a good shooter and they shoot 50% from the field.
丹尼·格林再次从外线出手。他投中了第六个三分，比赛回到了第二场。这种迷信认为，当进行罚球时，篮球运动员会处于一种顺风顺水的状态。人们相信篮球运动员会手感火热，而且在他们刚刚投进一个球之后，再次投进的几率会比刚刚投失一个球之后要高。埃普利说，篮球运动员并没有所谓的“连中”（streaks）。他的意思是，我们对这些连中做出了错误的结论。让我们假设他们是一个优秀的投手，在场上的命中率是50%。
That 50% probability is going to produce a lot more clumping. In the baskets, than people expect. People expect a coin flip, a 50% probability to alternate a lot more than it actually does. And so when you see randomness out in the world, it actually looks more ordered to you than it really is. Echelie described a party trick that demonstrates this phenomenon. You can do this too. Give everyone in the party a note card and have them write down what they think 30 coin flips would look like. H, if they think it will be heads, T, if they think it will be tails.
这种50%的概率会产生比人们预期的更多的聚集（clumping）。在进球方面，比人们预期的要多。人们期望抛硬币、50%的概率应该比实际情况交替出现得更多。因此，当你看到世界上的随机性时，它实际上比真实情况看起来更有序。埃普利描述了一个展示这种现象的派对把戏。你也可以这样做。给派对上的每个人一张便签纸，让他们写下他们认为抛30次硬币会是什么样子。如果他们认为是正面，就写H；如果他们认为是反面，就写T。
You then, as master magician, leave the room and you have one person come up and actually flip a coin 30 times. That person writes down the actual sequence of coin flips on a note card and then collects all the note cards, the real and the imagined sequences, and puts them together. You the magician then come back into the room and identify the card that was the real coin flip. And the way you do this is you look for the card that has the longest runs because people's imagination doesn't presume that a 50-50 probability will produce very long runs.
然后，作为魔术大师的你离开房间，让一个人上来真正抛30次硬币。那个人把硬币抛掷的真实顺序写在一张便签纸上，然后收集所有的便签纸——真实的和想象的序列，把它们混在一起。作为魔术师的你随后回到房间，找出那张记录了真实抛硬币结果的卡片。你辨别的方法是寻找拥有最长连续结果（runs）的卡片，因为人们的想象并不认为50对50的概率会产生很长的连续结果。
And so people's imagined coin flips will alternate more than the real coin flip will. And that's how you can identify the real one from the fake ones. And I think that illusion that we have, that randomness alternates, or as more fancy than it actually is, that there's less clumping is also the thing that gives rise to these other phenomena where we see randomness in the world, and we see more predictability or intentionality than actually exist in it. When we asked our listeners to share coincidences with us, many of them wrote in with really interesting examples of things that happened to them. One thing that I was
所以人们想象的抛硬币结果会比真正的抛硬币结果交替得更频繁。这就是你如何从虚假的卡片中识别出真实的卡片。我认为我们所拥有的那种错觉——即随机性是交替出现的，或者比实际情况更具花样，聚集团簇更少——也是导致其他现象的原因：我们在世界上看到随机性时，看到的往往比实际存在的更多可预测性或意向性。当我们请听众与我们分享巧合时，许多人写信分享了发生在他们身上的非常有趣的事情。有一件事让我
struck by is the sense that sometimes a coincidence seems more meaningful to you than it does to someone else. So for example, when I'm reading a book and I come by an unusual word and then someone in the room mentions that same word, to me it feels like it's a sign of something. But if I would have told you, I say, Nick, you know, this happened to me yesterday, you'd say, yeah, sure, that's going to happen once every month or so. It's exactly what you would expect if you believe the laws of probability. Why do you think it is that coincidences are more meaningful to us than to other people? That's a really good question. I actually don't know that I've seen any research that demonstrates that phenomena, but that
印象深刻，那就是有时一个巧合对你来说似乎比对其他人更有意义。比如，当我正在读一书，偶然看到一个不寻常的词，然后房间里的某个人提到了同一个词，对我来说，这感觉像是某种征兆。但如果我告诉你，我说：尼克，你知道吗，这事儿昨天发生在我身上了。你会说：哦，当然，这种事大概每个月左右就会发生一次。如果你相信概率定律，这正是你会预料到的情况。为什么你认为巧合对我们而言比对其他人更有意义呢？这真是个好问题。我其实不知道自己是否见过任何证明这种现象的研究，但
strikes me as a very compelling hypothesis. I think that's probably likely to be right. And I think the reason why coincidences seem very meaningful in the first place is that you're trying to explain them. You and I both thought of the word propeller at the same time. How on earth could that be that Shankar was thinking about propeller at the same time that I was?
这让我觉得是一个非常引人入胜的假设。我想这很可能是对的。我认为巧合之所以一开始看起来很有意义，是因为你正试图解释它们。你和我同时想到了“螺旋桨”（propeller）这个词。尚卡尔怎么可能在我想着螺旋桨的同时也在想着螺旋桨呢？
And so you're trying to explain that. You're focusing on that event that just happened to you. It has personal relevance to you. That makes it impactful. But it also makes you somewhat myopic. And what we don't think about are all of the other things that any of us in the room could have thought about at the same time, that might also have seemed amazing to us.
所以你正试图解释这一点。你把注意力集中在刚刚发生在你身上的那个事件上。它对你具有个人相关性。这让它产生了影响力。但这也让你变得有些目光短浅。而我们没有去想的是，房间里的我们任何人当时可能想到的所有其他事情，这些事情对我们来说也可能显得很神奇。
We're trying to explain this one thing because it's so meaningful to us. It just happened to us. Other people are less likely to be that myopic, I think, and so there would be likely to think about other things that could have happened to you, which would make it seem less amazing to them. We of course experience the Sarsals here at the show, when two listeners called in with
我们试图解释这一件事，因为它对我们太有意义了。它刚刚发生在我们身上。我想，其他人不太可能会那么目光短浅，因此他们可能会去想其他可能发生在身上的事情，这会让这件事对他们来说显得没那么神奇。我们在节目中当然也经历过这样的巧合，当时两位听众打来电话，
eerily similar coincidence stories. I describe these two stories to Nick about women who ran into people who turned out to live in the very same house where the women's parents had grown up. So these are not just two coincidences. These are two coincidences that both happened to us at Hidden Brain, which seems truly extraordinary, Nick. How could that possibly be that you get these two that are exactly the same as magic
分享了诡异相似的巧合故事。我向尼克描述了这两个关于女性的故事：她们遇到了那些碰巧住在女方父母长大的同一栋房子里的人。所以这不仅仅是两个巧合。这是两个恰巧都发生在《隐藏的大脑》这里的巧合，尼克，这看起来真的太不可思议了。怎么可能会有这两个故事一模一样，就像魔法一样
as what it is, Sean Carr? You're magical. That's really just all I wanted to hear you say, Nick, it's been 20 minutes to get that out of you. Yeah. Eventually we have to give into the laws of probability. There's nothing that can explain that, right? Nick, I want to thank you for talking with us today.
正如它本来的那样，尚卡尔？你太神奇了。这其实就是我一直想听你亲口说出来的话，尼克，为了让你说出这句话，我花了20分钟。是的。最终我们不得不向概率定律低头。没有什么可以解释这一点，对吧？尼克，我要感谢你今天与我们交谈。
Yeah, thanks for having me. Nick Eppley is the author of Mindwise, how we understand what others think, believe, feel, and want. This week's episode was produced by Mack Penman and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Chris Benderer, Karamakar Callison and Renee Clarke. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. There are so many people who make this podcast possible. We usually don't mention all of them in our credits.
好的，谢谢你们邀请我。尼克·埃普利是《心灵智慧：我们如何理解别人的想法、信念、感受和需求》一书的作者。本杰目的本周节目由麦克·彭曼（Mack Penman）制作，珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）剪辑。我们的团队还包括克里斯·本德尔（Chris Benderer）、卡拉马卡尔·卡利森（Karamakar Callison）和蕾妮·克拉克（Renee Clarke）。我们的主管制作人是塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。有这么多人让这个播客成为可能。我们通常不会在演职员表中提及所有这些人。
Starting today, we're going to acknowledge a different unsung hero each episode. This week, that person is Matilda P.R. who is a project manager here at NPR. She knows everything about everything. She's always generous with her time and her knowledge. Thank you, Matilda. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, give us a review. It'll help other people find the show.
从今天开始，我们每期节目都将表彰一位不同的幕后英雄。本周的那个人是马蒂尔达·P·R（Matilda P.R.），她是NPR的一名项目经理。她无所不知。她总是慷慨地奉献她的时间和知识。谢谢你，马蒂尔达。想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们，也可以在当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这期节目，请给我们写个好评。这会帮助其他人找到这个节目。
I'm Shankar Vaitanthu, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。